it seems like there might also be a ton
of other considerations you know if
you're thinking about like hearing
impairment visual impairment when people
are designing for all these users can
you compromise the design well the
product may be change too much yeah it's
a very good question and there there
definitely does seem like there's a lot
at first glance to really consider and
in actuality if you do leave all of
these considerations to the end of the
product cycle it it can compromise the
product because there's a lot of there's
a lot of rethinking and refactoring that
needs to go into just kind of fit these
things in and so that's why we're always
asking people and informing and
educating people on how to think of
these things early on I think when you
when you just look at the general steps
within the the design process all of the
points that when you're thinking about
accessibility they're integrated in
every step that you're already thinking
about so again with color contrast
you're already thinking about what is
your color palette going to be so then
just on top of that you have some some
additional standards to maybe try to
follow and look at to ensure that
there's enough contrast there okay we're
here at the Aqsa website I wanted to
bring this up because I feel like they
have a really good approach to Universal
Design and they have this great quote on
here that I wanted to read when we talk
about designing for accessibility or
Universal Design it's important to note
that that does not mean designing
products fully usable by everybody since
there is no product that can truly
fulfill the needs of all users but when
all users needs are taken into
consideration and the initial design
process the result is a product that can
be used by the broadest spectrum of
users so I feel like that's a great way
to kind of sum up that yes there is a
lot to consider but it's not about
making compromises in the end when you
do consider these things upfront you end
up with a better product overall yeah
that's good and how can an entrepreneur
learn more about accessibility what
resources are available to them the
great thing is there's a lot of
resources out there online a few just to
kind of rattle off our
the web content accessibility guidelines
which you can find online that's a
really thorough list of standards that
you would want to meet and need to meet
and they have great examples on there as
well and resources there are different
companies have provided their own design
guidelines Google is one of them which
you can see here this is the Google
accessibility website and our
specifically these are design guidelines
that we came up with which are based on
a lot of the standards that were
developed by the web content
accessibility guidelines Apple has a
great resource as well of their
accessibility design guidelines and
there's also some really interesting
tools out there there's plugins there's
a plug-in called CSEE that allows you to
kind of simulate what a your page or
site would look like with different
vision impairments as well as color
blindness yeah so there's there's a lot
that's out there great